first i want to say good afternoon to
all participants so this is our weekly
update
so far we in clark county have
administered more than 174 thousand
doses of vaccine
both pfizer and moderna
i also want to share with you that
recently we start offering the second
dose of vaccine
and those second doses
are being offered at las vegas
convention center for
all those individuals who receive their
first dose
at a facility that have been managed by
the
southern nevada healthy street or the
county and
and this is uh basically
our facility at 280 south dakota
boulevard
also a western high school
and uh and cashman cashman center
those are the the facilities where
people who received the first goals
back in gammary now will be able to
receive the second dose at the las vegas
convention center
uh regarding a vaccine allocation
as as we mentioned last week and
still is the issue our
our parsina locations are very limited
by now
we we are receiving somewhere
between 20 25 000
doses of vaccine per week and
we expect those numbers to increase in
the in the near future
but that's that's what we have right now
and
and we are working with our local
partners based
on on those numbers
regard regarding the
the coronavirus a pandemic
you know in clark county we have a more
than
200 000 cases reported so far
and unfortunately more than 3 000
deaths this is something that has
heavily impacted our community
and last week we notified the first case
of the
of the b117 strain which is the
the virus train first identified in the
united kingdom
and and now this week
we received a confirmation from the lab
that five additional cases of this
train have been identified here in
karakani
uh the important thing about those
five additional cases is that
all those are a close contacts of the
initial case
and this really shows the value of
contact tracing and
how how hard our investigators and
partners have been working
on on trying to identify a close contact
of the
cases that are investigated so at this
point
in krakoni there is a total of six
cases confirmed by this strain and and
this is something that
have been reported in in multiple states
across the country right now
i i also want to share with you that uh
starting today and we will be
reporting in weekly basis the
the the places of possible exposure is
important
important to emphasize the possible
exposure here because this is based on
information
collected through to our a contact
testing investigation
and and this is a specifically
when we asked a case
where they have been the last 10
14 days and and then they
they identified certain public places
where they have been so
any any particular case a
could identify multiple possible places
of exposure
in other words a place of possible
exposure
is not synonymous of place of exposure
so
by identifying a possible place
doesn't necessarily mean that the person
was infected at that place
but we take that information just to
span our work
our investigation and look for more
elements
into the decision making of how to
manage cases here in the county
yeah i will stop here and
i will uh invite our commissioner
marilyn kilpatik please thank you
uh dr lagann and i apologize i have a
standing meeting once a month
that i do within my district and so i
won't be able to stay on but i do want
to emphasize
that you know it's been more than 174
000 vaccines as you said in a short time
and i encourage the public to be patient
with us
this is all new to all of us and i
encourage the press to help us
um get through some of this rocky times
right it's hard i t
systems are up and down we're trying to
work through that we're trying to get
some clarifications for
everyone uh the call center we've made
some clarifications to the call center
this morning
uh so we encourage people to be patient
to work with this nobody wants to get
the vaccines
out more than the southern nevada health
district because we know how important
that is to our community
but it is gonna we are gonna have some
rocky moments so
remember that's that anytime we do
something new we have
some rockiness but i think joanne will
explain to you
that we'll be sending out emails to the
people that were
first getting that um dose um
i think she'll explain that to you i
think chief steinbach will be able to
tell you um how we're ready to go um
in the events that we get a lot more
vaccines
i think um councilman black will be able
to
really tell you that the health district
is focused and working together several
meetings a day to stay on target
and lastly i just want to
acknowledge that dr lagon is our
chief health officer and we couldn't be
prouder to have someone with the
experience
who has led us through this and
apologize i can't stay on
dr lagon but if there's any questions
i'm happy to meet with anyone but
remember we're a collaborative team from
the state to
the local jurisdiction we all work
together
and we are all have one mission and
that's to get as many vaccines into
the arms of folks that need it and to
safely keep our community going so
thank you dr lagann thank you
okay thank you commissioner um i will
invite
a councilman escort black he's the
chairman of our board of health
scope please thank you dr lagann and
thank you commissioner kirkpatrick
she's done a tremendous job as a
co-leader with dr lagann on this effort
i really appreciate all that she's done
just like she mentioned i personally
know and i know everyone at the health
district is fully cognizant and aware
that there are many people in our
community that are frustrated because
you're unable to get the appointments
for the vaccine right away
i know in a perfect world we all want to
know exactly when
exactly where and exactly how we will be
able to get vaccinated
but i i hope you will all bear in mind
and think i it's important to remember
that we're literally building this
infrastructure to deliver the vaccines
at the same time
that we're receiving the vaccines to
distribute them
we're only able to provide the vaccine
it's also at the rate that we get them
so we've built tremendous capacity
uh chief steinbeck and all the emergency
managers have done a tremendous job
building the capacity
and the good news is we are weekly
getting vaccines we're getting supplies
every week and we're hopeful that that
vaccine allocation will increase over
the coming weeks and
as it increases we are certainly capable
of utilizing
every one of those doses in our
community in a pretty expeditious way
um i just want you to know that at the
health strict work health district we're
committed
to providing you updated information as
soon as it comes available
both through media releases and as well
as this weekly media access that we
provide
also the health district is working
diligently to provide services at the
highest level we're trying to improve as
we go
we're literally on the vaccine train the
train is moving down the tracks we're
building momentum
but we're also simultaneously building
the tracks right out in front of the
train as we go and so
thankful for the patients thankful for
the media to help us get the word out
to talk about locations and vaccine
availability
and we're all going to collectively
continue to do our best to get
vaccinations to everyone in our
community
who desire dr lagann okay
thank you scott thank you okay i will
ask
you andrey pepper and she is our chief
i'm 83 nurse i'm also
leading our vaccination campaign joanne
please
joanne let's get you unmuted
thank you okay good afternoon
um so our vaccine campaign
has been uh maximized every week
that we've received the vaccine we are
getting about uh 12 uh 25
23 to 25 000 per week in
clark county and we are using that every
week so
i think the number 175 about um
is a very satisfying number um
we are focusing still on the same tiers
the over 70 group the um
the frontline community support up to
continuity of governance
and we are really focusing on education
this week
and we have some strategies for that um
we also are fine-tuning our appointment
scheduling system
so that when uh individuals uh are
getting vaccines
today at cashman that they have a
notification of either email or text
that um they can um
get their appointment right away so uh
that that will we're still fine-tuning
that a little bit
getting that set up uh but it's getting
better much much better every day
so um that's all i have
okay thank you and okay i will introduce
now
chief steinberg er chief please
miss doctor thank you dr again and i
publicly i'd like to say congratulations
we're very happy that uh you're
our full-time um doctor in charge of
this now thank you so much
congratulations uh all i'll say to this
story is
uh we're ready to maximize our
operations as uh
councilman black said uh we're we're
ready to push out more vaccine we just
need more supplies
we have many more sites that are
ready and able to be opened up today is
our first time that
we've opened up a site down in laughlin
to serve that community
but throughout all of southern nevada we
stand
ready to open up many more
uh sites and to maximize the sites that
are that we currently have open
to get this community vaccinated and and
as as back to normal as we possibly can
so
we stand waiting and i i await any
questions that you might have
thank you chef thank you okay uh cody
would you please go
now to the questions certainly let's go
on and open the floor for any media to
ask the questions please use the raise
hand feature
spanish language will save to the end
with a special session with dr legend
first up today is jacqueline schultz
from fox 5.
hi everyone uh thank you all so much for
uh uh i know for the past few days given
more clarification on second doses and
uh figuring out the appointment system
um a lot of yours are calling with this
question just as a practical
um your first some seniors or other
essential workers if your dose second
dose is coming up
and you still can't get an appointment
uh
what are your options should you
las vegas convention center um and
explain your situation
and if you could give our viewers some
guidance on like what
what's your time frame window uh for
when you need to
do so and get your uh second dose we
know
visor 21 days maderana 28 but um
is is that what do you need to do
if you're in a time crunch
okay uh first uh
i i will tell you that uh the cdc
recommendation for the second dose
is yes 21 days for pfizer
and 28 days for moderna
and and then there is a
also a time frame of three to four days
to
even after that
that day but the recent cdc
guidelines and considerations also
also point out to today to the
possibility
when a person is unable to
to get the the second dose just within
that original recommended time frame
because of many reasons who could be
there uh
they they consider that it it is still
acceptable
and and effective to to get that second
dose
between between the first six weeks or
42 days
from the initial dose up to the second
dose
so those are the the current cdc
uh recommendations which keep the
the original time frame of 21 to 28
those
days as the at the at the valid one
but the consideration for people who
might
miss that initial opportunity they
still have up to 6 weeks to
to complete that but i will ask joanne
to talk about a second second those
appointments and what's
what's going on here and what we are
doing to address that
johan please
again okay um the second dose
appointments
as of january 19th 18th
somewhere in there we switched our
appointment system
prior to that uh we
we used uh our online system
and so with that we will
be emailing individuals um and
and giving them the link for them to
make that appointment
when we did that and when we published
it on our website it really overwhelmed
the system
so we are fixing that by uh sending it
out again
and uh getting an opportunity for those
people to
make appointments so if you've had your
vaccine
from a january 4 to like the 19th
uh we'll we will be emailing you for
that
um for the other uh when we went to
online registration where you would
actually give your birth date all the
demographic information
after you vaccinated you would get a
link
that would give you the opportunity to
make
an appointment we had a some technical
problems with that
and so we do have um
a link open on the
website so that people are able to make
that appointment
and we we can send out some more
information about that
so uh keep in mind that
our clinics uh we we need to open them
yet
um you should check back in a day or two
and uh either schedule or reschedule
and then call um 702
5759 1900
to uh if you have still have problems
then to go to that website and they will
assist you
okay thank you aaron thank you hi corey
please
next question is from megan messerly i'm
muting you now
hi there thanks again for doing these
every week um
kind of bouncing off of that last
question
just to clarify um i i've been hearing
from some folks as well
um you know who told me that you know
they they wanted to get their dose
whatever 21 days out 28 days out exactly
on the day
and they were able to get it and they
haven't been able um to make those
appointments and then you know they're
they're clicking around other days and
seeing
those are full so based on on your last
answer there
joanne i mean is the hope that everyone
who wants an appointment
21 days or 20 days whatever their
allotted time is
we'll be able to get one on that day i
understand that you know they can get it
you know later if scheduling conflicts
or what have you you know within that
um period but it seems like based on i
mean you know when they got their first
dose
uh the state knows when they got their
first dose those doses are ordered based
on that schedule so it seems like people
should be able uh to get doses on on
that date so with these corrections and
and the emails and everything you're
talking about
should everyone who um you know wants an
appointment on that first possible day
they can get their second dose
be able to get one that day correct or
or
close to it um like dr lagann said there
is some
um there is some grace period with that
three to four before it
and then after up to 42 days but
um i mean typically we would
want to get it on the same day we only
used moderna
up until around january
so it should be at the four-week um the
28-day
uh time frame uh so that
that will uh that's good information to
have for individuals and they
they have to have gotten the vaccine
with us so
as i've uh discussed before
is that every vaccine provider
gets the first dose and then they order
four or three to four weeks later they
can order that second dose
and they can only order that amount so
last week we ordered
um 9 200 for this week
and we know that that's how many we had
because we
are able to take it off of our
electronic system
and so that's how many appointments we
made so
there there were some individuals that
were making first dose appointments at
the las vegas convention center
not a good idea we won't be able to take
you
because then we will be taking a second
dose from
someone else so we are we are not doing
that we
notified people that they should try to
get on the website
and then get that first go so
and if you get your vaccine at your
employer
or umc or unlv any of the other partners
you're going to need to go back there
because again
we don't have your dose on hand for you
if people come from out of state
or something like that then they can
call us and
um we can try to assist them
next question is from mr joe moller
hey there uh joe muller from channel 8
here uh i am
i have a couple questions i am currently
working with a woman
who told me that she went on to make an
appointment and it's
the website keeps crashing and she's
worried she won't get to her
her uh second date she's supposed to get
it by
and she had called the health district
and they told her
she won't be sending emails anymore um
she said that was a change as of
yesterday and she's a little bit
confused and i'm sure
there's others out there like that as
well so i don't know if we get some
clarification on that
correct so uh we we did send some emails
out
um we sent it out twice for the first
round
up until people that received their
vaccine
um until the 10th and now we're going to
send another one for that next group
that got their vaccines through the 19.
um after if they if they went through
the um clinic and they had to give all
of their stuff electronically
like um birth date and all that then
they should have received a text and
email
directly to their phone afterwards so
um so if they have trouble they should
try to call us
yes we've had a lot of phone calls we
just got
more capacity for people to answer the
phones today
and it's changing every day and
um you know we're trying to work through
these issues so people can get through
to us
perfect and real quick the lapland
location i noticed this morning there
was a substantial
openings this morning if you go to
laughlin are you going to end up
getting your second dose up in las vegas
no
no offline is only first dose
and it's only lockland residents or is
it anybody in clark county
well we targeted i mean we obviously
advertised for that area
there really isn't a result residency
requirement so but we do
we do encourage communities to reach out
to their
community members so that they can
receive that vaccine appropriately
thank you
and i would like to say too that like
you said
some uh if people make appointments
they should keep them if they're they're
not eligible or they change their mind
please cancel so that we can get more uh
people in
and please don't just not show um it's
very
disheartening to see that we have
a less of a crowd because people didn't
cancel appointments
or did them inappropriately
next up is miss mary hines thank you and
good afternoon
sorry but i am unclear on what the
guidance is for people who have been
unable to schedule these second
appointments
um
do you are they just to keep trying on
the website
and are you fixing the website
and if if at such a time as they are due
and they still don't have an appointment
should they just show up
at the convention center so it really
depends
when they got that vaccine okay so if
they got that vaccine
uh somewhere between january 4 and and
the 10th
i know it sounds so complicated but we
we
had some we had a lot of issues so
january
up until about january 10th or so uh we
sent out two emails
and um uh opened up
opened up the appointments and they did
have opportunity to get it then
we're sending out another email for
those through january 19
and they will have an opportunity to get
um
an appointment and that should go out
today or tomorrow
from then on when they were on the
electronic system
um we are working on that
so that's they're not due till february
19th so they may not be able to get an
appointment right now
but they will by the time they're due
yeah you and us you also want to to make
sure that we have a phone line where
they can call the
right yeah next question is from mr
michael davidson
sorry i had to get myself unmuted there
thank you for uh taking my question i
had a question about the
uh possible exposure location data that
began being published on the
health district website uh today um
so back in september many months ago
seems like another lifetime
at this point um there were reports of
possible exposure locations
being published by the state that the
review journal and other news outlets
obtained
through a public records request the
state stopped publishing those
we asked the health district if they
would continue to do that analysis
and at the time in september we were
told by a health district official that
the quotes
the reports would quote provide limited
if any value
while we are experiencing community
spread of the virus end quote
now obviously the health district is
starting today publishing this
uh possible exposure location data and
i'm just wondering
what's changed um is the snhd finding
more value in this data right now and
getting it out to the public
how should the public use this data in
their day-to-day lives if at all
when they're considering everything that
we publish and make public
and what is the snhd doing with it
internally to
uh you know shape their coveted response
sure thank you corey i will take this
one well uh
as we said before this this data
it has a limited value and the reason
for that is because
this is a disease that has a relatively
large incubation period is up to 14 days
during that period people who become
a confirmed cases have been at
a multiple places usually and
and and when they identify
a possible place of exposure
all or what we call the possible places
exposure is
we are referring to two public places
that
people tend to remember the most
but not necessarily means that
the person was actually infected at that
site
so that's the limitation of that on that
of that data that kind of information
now why
are we posting that information because
we are receiving is so many
calls uh people asking for
for a for a location in from
that kind of a possible exposure and
and we don't want to submit our our
thing to
to the stress of of of this you know
sorry this is sorry i'm really sorry so
we we don't want to submit our team to
to the uh continuous
expression of creating report if
that they're being asked for the the
same kind of information so
a a a way for us to actually
safe time for from for our thing
is is to post that information so
if anyone has an interest in
in in that kind of data it is available
on our website we
having said that we we use that that
information also
with our environmental health division
our inspectors and we share that with
them
and if they find any
any kind of of trend or in
certain locations they they might decide
and go
and do inspections or communicate with
people
on those places so this is a
the way that we manage that information
but we we consider that
for the general public it's it has a
some information but really limited in
terms of
being able to make any conclusions from
that data
thank you
before we move further let's um mary
wants us to circle back
you said there's a phone number that
people can call regarding second dose
appointments
can we please give out that phone number
and explain who should be using that
number
yes i'm just going to confirm that and
i'll put that in the chat
thank you joanne our next question today
comes from alexis gory
i'm muting you now
trying to
how about there can you hear me now yes
ma'am okay hello
hello everyone um so um kind of a
two-part question here so
with the error that people are getting
trying to make appointments right now
um is that just a capacity issue is the
website um you know shut down because
too many people are trying to make
appointments
and also how many vaccines did we get
this week
versus how many we were told we were
supposed to be getting um and if there's
a difference
why jordan
so the you're talking about the number
of vaccines we were given
versus i'm sorry
yeah she's asking he's asking two things
about
uh uh what what what might be happening
with a
registration system what people struggle
to
get an appointment okay and also
uh what what is the difference between
our varsity allocation this week compare
weeks oh yeah okay yes our vaccine
allocation has been the same and we
expect it to be the same next
next week we just received that news
today
and um the uh the registration
system um they
it's uh it's more complete and more
um uh it gets them ready to
go to the clinic i would say so that it
takes a little bit longer
where your ass were asking questions
about your date of birth demographics
and your health status
so it's a little more complicated than
it was before
so if people need their first dose um
then um they should keep in mind that we
only do
we only set up the appointments three
days in advance for first dose so they
should check every day
because and the reason we have to do
that is because we don't know what kind
of vaccine
we will be getting so typically we get
our um shipment on monday
and we have our clinics later in the
week
and then we do some adjustments and then
we really know for sure how many
appointments we can do
for example we had some clinics
scheduled this week
and now we increase the capacity so now
appointments opened up
does that answer your question i hope
yeah i think it does thank you our next
question
is from fox5 i'm unmuting you right now
let's see if this works there you go
hi can you hear me
we sure can please go ahead thank you
from fox 5 and um the questions i have
are um
if you could maybe talk about the
demographic breakdown of who's received
the vaccine so far
um i think that's been touched on before
but we just like them
from that and then um a second question
i had
was if we if you guys know when we can
expect
another lane to open up or another lane
to be added to the groups of eligible
people to get the vaccine thank you
i do dr lagann i do have that
uh what do you have in front of you yeah
i do have it in front of me actually
i was just looking at this today we had
received it
um so uh this is for clark
county at yes four o'clock county
and so it's 174 665
and we have a race and ethnicity
of 40 percent white and
we have 16 percent unknown
and 16 other 11 asian
10 hispanic and 4 percent uh black
and or african american and then
our female group
is doing a little better than the males
i would say
they're at 58 percent and uh males are
41
age groups um we have
a 42 percent of above the 65 plus
um that i would i know we're doing 70
plus
i i think that that just isn't the re
the way that it's reported out but uh
probably why
the 65 percent or 65 plus
is that there is you know individuals
who are working
still at 65 to 70 so
and uh
nine percent were unknown so i don't i
don't know they didn't know how old they
were i guess
it's probably because we didn't get the
date of birth or things like that
the next biggest uh group is 28
of 25 to 49 and i'm not surprised by
that either because
if you think about it we've been doing a
lot of um
you know first responders law
enforcement
medical um those individuals so
yes
next question today comes from dana
gentry
i'm muting you trying to there we go
hi thank you for taking my question um
what are you doing
to address the data that you just
discussed about the demographic
disparities
specifically for hispanic and black
populations
sure thank you well
what we're doing or or i would say i
would rather say what we plan to do
because
these are two differences what we have
been doing so far
with our vaccination sites we we have
been
utilizing a mostly a large vaccination
size
cashman the high school
at uh at western and also
a mac middle school
all those facilities are
are located with with within or
or or very close to to the sick calls
where we have
our highest incidence of of going
now uh we we do have the
the distribution of of people who have
been vaccinated
by sick code and
we when we map that distribution of
people who have been vaccinated
actually it doesn't match uh the sick
codes with the highest
uh a number of of
comic cases in krakowic and
and and there are perhaps a couple of
reasons for that one
is that a the the initial groups that we
vaccinated well
healthcare workers and law enforcement
groups
they they they are you know widely
distributed
distributed through this community but
also
the issue that regardless of where you
locate a mass vaccination site
people will register from any any area
in the county and they will actually
drive there so in other words
we have a for example the high school
at the middle mac middle school which is
in the east las vegas
well it doesn't mean that if
only people from that area is registered
actually
that is very possible that a lot of
people who
live in other areas of country register
into those sites so this is what we have
been experiencing
and and and the way that we
that we are looking to address this
issue
of of access and and also of course the
inequalities it is that it is to move
in in a different direction in in the
near future
and i'm going to start uh deploying
a small vaccination size or
strike things in those in those sequels
in partnership with the with the
local elected officials
a community based organizations and
and groups that are highly respected on
these areas
so we can ensure that if we
allocate 1000 vaccines
to c code x because we want to make sure
that we
are targeting that that area uh
those those 1000 shots are actually
a monitor to people who live in that
area with uh
we understand that
everybody needs a vaccine and and they
are you know being vaccinated
is is important for each resident of
this community
but also we we are aware that
there are certain areas of this
community that are being
heavily affected by the pandemic and
and we need to to specifically
target those areas to make sure that
that we decrease
the the rate of transmission
in those areas so that's that's how we
are planning to do this because
certainly we cannot rely
on just the mass fascination side being
located in
in that area because it doesn't
guarantee that people
in the in the heavily affected area
we get vaccinated there
we're going to take one more voice call
today this one's from
david charns i'm an unmuting announcer
there you go and i thank you guys for
taking our questions today
um i wanted to circle back um and follow
up on michael's question about the
data that is uh starting to be posted
today regarding possible exposure data
as he mentioned obviously this is
something we have been asking for
for months the last data was released in
september
several of my public records requests
about this have been denied
um as recent as two weeks ago when i
received an email back
from your legal department that said
quote
uh we are not able to make a
determination where an
individual obtained covet 19. um
over the past several weeks i have gone
back and forth
with the communications office and the
legal department
basically going over semantics but i was
looking for and then all of a sudden
today the data is posted
so i'd like to know uh why today
uh it was decided to post this exposure
data
when uh we are now almost a year into
this pandemic
and it seems like we had this data all
along thank you
sure thank you corey well uh i believe i
referred to that before and i will
say say the same thing again
we we are
posting this information because we are
receiving a lot of questions about
a side as possible which
we call a possible size exposure
we we don't want our team to
be submitted every every single week
to work on on those kind of requests
so a a way to address that is
is by posting that information making
that information available and
and that's the decision that we make and
that's and that's the reason why
you are seeing that information there
i cannot comment on on your interaction
with
our office in previous weeks because i
am not fully aware of what that
interaction was so
i would just leave but
we made the decision to quote
information so we don't receive
that many requests for that kind of data
thank you